[Music]
a mother and her son trek across an
endless desert wearing special skin
tight suits to dissipate heat and
recycle moisture the travelers aren't
worried about dying of thirst their
fears are much greater the pair try to
walk without rhythm letting the
vibrations of their footsteps blend into
the shifting sands but soon the sound of
the desert is drowned out by a louder
hissing as a mound of sand races towards
them the pair's unnatural gait turns
into a sprint the two clamber into a
nearby rock face as a sand worm 400
meters long bursts from the desert floor
this is the world of doom written by
Frank Herbert and published in 1965 dune
takes place in a far-flung future where
humanity rules the stars in a giant
feudal empire this medieval motif goes
beyond just the government unlike most
interstellar sci-fi Herbert's humans
conquered the stars without any
computers following an ancient war with
robots humanity has forbidden the
construction of any machine in the
likeness of a human mind but rather than
stifling their expansion this edict
forced humans to evolve in startling
ways becoming biological computers
psychic witches and prescient space
pilots members of these super-powered
factions are regularly employed by
various noble houses all competing for
power and new planets to add to their
kingdoms but almost all these superhuman
skills
rely on the same precious resource the
spice this mystical crop also known as
melange is essential for all space
travel making it the cornerstone of the
galactic economy and it only grows on
the desert planet Iraq
a dangerous and inhospitable world whose
native inhabitants have long rebelled
against the Empire Arrakis also called
doom is the setting for Herbert's novel
which follows Paul of the noble house
Atreides the book begins with Paul's
family being assigned control of doom as
part of an elaborate plot by their sworn
enemies the sadistic slave drivers of
house Harkonnen the conflict between
these houses appends the delicate
political balance on eraqus soon Paul is
catapulted into the middle of a
planetary revolution where he must prove
himself capable of leading and surviving
on this hostile desert world but Arrakis
is not simply an endless sea of sand
Herbert was an avid environmentalist
who spent over five years creating dunes
complex ecosystem the planet is
checkered with climate belts and wind
tunnels that have shaped its rocky
topography different temperate zones
produce varying desert flora and almost
every element of dunes ecosystem works
together to produce the planet's
essential export Herbert's world
building also includes a rich web of
philosophy and religion Paul's mother
Jessica is a member of the Bene Jesuit
an ancient cult of spice assisted
psychics sometimes called witches for
their mysterious powers the bene Jesuit
have operated as a shadow government for
millennia in an effort to guide society
towards enlightenment
similarly ancient are the Mentats human
computers capable of processing
incredible amounts of data while the
Mentats are bastions of logic and reason
their results are not mere calculations
but rather streams of constantly
shifting possibilities however no group
is more central to Doon than the Fremen
natives of Arrakis they are the keepers
of the planets
and secrets Paul's journey takes him
deep into the femen's exclusive
Brotherhood where he must prove himself
trustworthy in a series of increasingly
deadly challenges all these factions
have deep histories that pervade the
text and Herbert also incorporates that
sense of scale into the book structure
each chapter begins with a quote from a
future history book recalling elements
of the events that are about to unfold
the book also contains in universe
appendices that further explore the
Empire's history alongside a glossary of
words like Dom jabbar and Shai allude
Dunes epic story continues to unfold
over a six books agha that spans
millennia but every story of Arrakis
future begins here as paul pursues a
path that is dangerous demanding and
always on the verge of being consumed by
the oncoming storm for all our science
fiction fans out there we think you'll
love Octavia Butler and if you're
inspired enough to put pen to paper
check out this video on building
fictional worlds
[Music]